[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end nous allons
parler actualités mais aussi loisirs et
voici les titres de ce vendredi 12
février
depuis une semaine une polémique fait
rage autour de didier lemaire professeur
de philosophie au lycée de la plaine de
nolf à trappes
il dit être inquiet de la radicalisation
religieuse importante pour réagir à ce
sujet nous recevrons marie-laure segal
de l'association d'y réagir un cercle de
réflexion et d'action contre l'emprise
islamistes le professeur a fait partie
de cette association également à
l'occasion du nouvel an chinois la
plateforme qui nous vient de lancer
l'apprentissage du mandarin lancé en
2019 qui osent permet aux franciliens
d'apprendre des langues étrangères comme
l'anglais ou encore le portugais le
mandarin sera la première langue
extra-européenne de la plateforme
enfin nous vous proposerons aussi les
idées sorties et loisirs de sceller à
400 go avec du bien-être et bien sûr la
saint valentin qui a lieu ce week end
nous parlerons aussi du résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
juste avant cela les élus de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont réunis en conseil jeudi
11 février un conseil en visioconférence
ou a été présentée notamment le rapport
de la chambre régionale des comptes
elle a pointé la bonne gestion
financière de l'agglomération autre
point à l'ordre du jour le règlement
local de publicité intercommunale ce
projet doit permettre d'encadrer
l'impact des dispositifs publicitaires
sur le cadre de vie d'harmoniser la
réglementation locale sur le territoire
également ce règlement a été soumis à
une enquête publique les élus devaient
donc se prononcer sur les deux réserves
et six recommandations du commissaire
enquêteur parmi lesquelles par exemple
l'extinction nature des publicités
lumineuses des abribus après le dernier
passage des transports publics
enfin le document cadre relatif aux
orientations stratégiques en matière
d'attribution de logements sociaux et de
la chartre de relogement a été présenté
aux élus
cela doit permettre d'assurer un
meilleur équilibre territorial de
l'occupation du parc locatif mais
également
encadré et définir la mise en oeuvre des
opérations de relogement un point à
l'ordre du jour qui a d'ailleurs fait
débat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
achevée au début de l'année 2000 21 la
digue de montesson protège les habitants
des crues récurrentes de la scène elle
les a d'ailleurs protéger la semaine
dernière lorsque les yvelines était en
alerte orange crues et inondations
prolongement de la digue de sartrouville
c'est l'aboutissement d'un dossier de
longue date reportage de bixente mais
rien senti steben on aura pas d'eau à la
cave parce que deux ans de suite on a eu
de l'eau je crois que ceux dits glad
nous a changé la vie achevé juste à
temps la nouvelle digue de montesson est
fonctionnel depuis le début de l'année
2000 21 longues de 750 mètres elle a
protégé pour la première fois les
habitants de la crue de la seine les
premiers en est content surtout sont les
riverains qui enfin ont les pieds au sec
à montesson les précédentes grandes
crues vous aviez deux mètres dans les
rues de vielles circuler quelques fois
c'est le même arrivé en petite en
petites barques les les les cavs étaient
inondés les jardins étaient inondées
c'était vraiment terrible depuis
toujours les montées sonné subissait les
assauts du fleuve alors que leurs
voisins de sartrouville étaient protégés
par leurs propres dit qu un prolongement
initié par l'ancien maire de montesson
jean françois bayle un dossier que de
longue haleine que nous avons mené avec
mon prédécesseur surtout qu'ils étaient
à l'initiative depuis de nombreuses
années sur ce dossier jean françois
bayle qui a été un élu très punchy sur
ce dossier qui a su être embêtant et il
faut parfois des élus un peu embêtant
pour faire avancer les sujets débuté en
2019 le chantier a coûté environ 14
millions d'euros pour lequel le
département des yvelines a contribué à
hauteur de 20% depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années c'est vrai que c'était un des
grands dossiers du département à des
plus coûteux aussi qui a débouché
aujourd'hui les habitants sont sereins
face à la montée des eaux d'ailleurs
promeneurs et joggeurs se sont déjà
approprié l'endroit qui leur offre un
panorama du fleuve
et je rappelle que le département des
yvelines est toujours placés en
vigilance jaune cru neige verglas et
grand froid ce vendredi m nous
accueillons maintenant nicolas d'andry
bonsoir l'instant alors c'est un outil
numérique dont vous allez nous parler
qui permet aux franciliens d'apprendre
des langues étrangères la plateforme qui
osent elles proposent d'ailleurs depuis
ce vendredi 12 février un nouvel
apprentissage avec l'enseignement du
chinois
effectivement l honneur et c'est la
région ile de france qui a choisi le
nouvel an chinois option fêtons le
nouvel an chinois aujourd'hui pour
intégrer des leçon de mandarin vous
serez plongés dans une mini série ou
vous suivrez edwards qui s'installe en
colocation avec deux jeunes chinois
vicky et chine à travers des vidéos d
écoute vous apprendrez le vocabulaire de
base des caractères chinois ou encore
l'écriture phonétique
c'est donc une nouveauté pour cette
plate forme créée par la région
ile-de-france comme vous l'avez rappelé
est là pour l'apprentissage du mandarin
mais il ya déjà de nombreuses langues
qu'on peut apprendre sur qui et c'est
vrai cinq langues au total en plus du
chinois
vous avez l'anglais l'allemand
l'espagnol le portugais et le français
langue étrangère cette plateforme a été
lancé en 2019 par la région ile de
france
c'est un apprentissage ludique à travers
des extraits de films de séries ou de
documentaires mais vous pouvez aussi
obtenir un apprentissage sur mesure avec
du vocabulaire dédiés à des secteurs
d'activités thématiques particulières
comme la restauration la sécurité la
vente ou encore la finance pour suivre
votre progression vous avez un tableau
de bord l'objectif est affiché par la
région c'est de renforcer les
compétences linguistiques des
franciliens et aujourd'hui la plateforme
compte 225 qu'il inscrit
alors c'est gratuit et le site pour y
accéder s'affiche en bas de l'écran et
j'espère que vous apprendrez le mandarin
chimie aime quoi et les ce qui signifie
une bonne année en chinois et ben merci
bonne année aussi avoué je le fais en
français merci nicolas landry pour
toutes ces précisions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité de la semaine c'est bixente
mais rien senti steban qu'il use à qui
nous la résume pardon en 78 secondes
[Musique]
une vague de froid qui persiste le
département étaient sous vigilance tout
au long de la semaine des fortes chutes
de neige sont tombés dans la nuit du
mardi 9 février entraînant une fermeture
des établissements et transports
scolaires le mercredi
autre phénomène naturel la crue de la
seine plusieurs communes ont été
touchées par la montée du fleuve une
surveillance devenue récurrente en hiver
à l'image des bateliers du bras de marly
préparer pour les éventuels débordements
depuis lundi les étudiants de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines peuvent
retourner en cours en présentiel pour la
promotion de droits
ce sont environ 300 élèves présents
contre 3000 habituellement 33 pour cent
des étudiantes souffrent de précarité
menstruel dans les universités
françaises
l'association poèmes de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines a
décidé d'agir en organisant des
distributions gratuites de protection
hygiénique la région ile-de-france va
quant à elle installer des distributeurs
de protection mensuel les 465 lycées
publics devraient en être équipés
bientôt le bois de l'étang au coeur des
tensions à la verrière contrairement à
son projet initial de rénovation du
quartier le maire nicolas d'un ville
souhaite vous désormais une démolition
de 214 à 264 logements
un dossier qui suscite certaines
oppositions au sein du conseil municipal
et parmi les habitants
[Musique]
et la principale actualité de cette
semaine c'était une polémique autour de
didier lemaire professeur de philosophie
au lycée de la plaine de 9 à trappes
il dit être inquiet de la progression du
communautarisme et d'une radicalisation
religieuse importante au sein de trappes
suite à cela toute la semaine de
nombreuses réactions se sont succédé ce
vendredi matin c'est jean michel
blanquer air ministre de l'éducation qui
s'est exprimé lui aussi suite à une
distribution de tracts devant et dans
l'établissement scolaire par des élus de
la ville
le ministre je cite condamne fermement
cette intrusion dans un établissement
scolaire et apporte son complet soutien
à la communauté éducative choqués par
cet acte ils rappellent que les
personnels et les élèves d'un
établissement ne sauraient être
utilisées à des fins de politique locale
il termine son propos en signifiant que
l'académie de versailles a pris contact
avec le maire de trappes ali rabais pour
lui signifier sa désapprobation pour
continuer à parler de ce sujet notre
invité cette semaine marie laure segal
bonsoir vous êtes une ancienne
professeur de philosophie et vous faites
partie vous êtes même responsable une
des responsables de l'association d'y
réagir située à trappes
alors je le rappelle c'est l'association
c'est un cercle de réflexion et d'action
contre l'emprise islamistes le
professeur didier lemaire a fait partie
de votre association
vous avez même été co signataire
ensemble d'une lettre envoyée au
président de la république
emmanuel macron en 2018 si je me trompe
pas suite à la parution d'un livre sur
trappe et le problème de la
radicalisation des jeunes d'abord
première question marie-laure segal que
pensez-vous des constat de didier le
maire dont on a entendu parler toute
cette semaine lorsqu'il s'agit de
dénoncer des pratiques communautaires la
possibilité
d'échangés quand on est en classe avec
des élèves qui semblent tout de suite
connaître la vérité avec lesquels on ne
peut pas du tout discuté ou bien essayer
de les faire changer d'avis moi j'ai
déjà connu ça il ya 20 ans hélas ou même
25 ans puisque j'ai pris ma retraite
donc dans les années 2000 et j'ai été
justement l'objet d'une plainte
est ce que vous comprenez les critiques
les amalgames on a pu entendre cette
semaine qu'ils seraient d'extrême droite
en tout cas politique est ce que vous
pouvez entendre comprendre cela moi je
pense que didier lemaire est quelqu'un
qui qui n'est pas du tout quelqu'un de
droite où je pense qu'il a on a on
partage beaucoup de valeurs communes
en tous les cas ce qui concerne les
valeurs républicaines bon il a il a été
interviewé dans des journaux de droite
donc ça a sûrement contribué à cette
envie de trop vite jugé on adore
aujourd'hui mettre des étiquettes sur
les gens maintenant tous les propos que
tient didier je ne les approuve pas on a
il a d'ailleurs quitté notre association
pour faire un peu cavalier seul c'est
quelqu'un de très brillant et qui
trouvaient que la vie associative avec
son fonctionnement démocratique
souvent ça suppose des compromis des
lenteurs et voilà et justement on va
parler d'autres associations dont
l'association d'y réagir elle est située
à trappes dans l est pas si tu attrapes
a ainsi tué alors et elancourt island
pour pardonner mon erreur et on fait
donc c'est bien parce que il se passe
des choses à trappes entre autres et
d'ailleurs on a organisé déjà un débat
atra au café des merisiers bon on n'a
pas droit puisque trente personnes
c'était avant avant la qu'ovide en
février l'année dernière ou alors oui je
sais ça c'était avant le confinement et
donc c'est pour dire que la ville de
trappes et pleine de richesses on peut
faire beaucoup de choses à trappes
il n'y a pas du tout que
les islamistes de loin de moi de dire ça
j'ai été moi-même responsables
d'associations et donc je pense que il
faut nuancer ses propos concernant la
ville de trappes
même si il y à vraiment une inquiétude
quant à la montée de cette emprise
islamistes qui hélas exerce en priorité
sur les jeunes et donc quelle est la
solution pour vous quelles sont les
pistes de solution du moins ce que la
solution si on l'avait voilà en tout cas
les pistes de solution pour lutter
contre cette montée de la radicalisation
du communautarisme chez les jeunes
attrape ou même ailleurs
je pense qu'il faut essayer d'organiser
beaucoup plus donc d'instances où on
peut dialoguer avec les élèves sans
doute en dehors des cours ou bien que ce
soit compris dans le bain dans le temps
scolaire
il faut absolument arriver à lutter
contre ce clivage qui existe et que je
se ressentait déjà il ya vingt ans entre
ce que vivent les jeunes et c'est ce que
dit très bien aussi didier à ce niveau
là au niveau pédagogique ce que vivent
les élèves dans leur famille et ce qui
se passe à l'école et on a l'impression
que c'est comme s'il était schizophrène
c'est un mot fort ils seront 100 me pour
pour y pourvoir pour vous expliquer
n'est pas qu'ils sont schizophrènes mais
ils vivent deux réalités totalement
différente et je pense que c'est on en
arrive à ce que beaucoup de jeunes use
de la taqiyya latakia ça veut dire belle
espèce de dissimulation qui fait qu' on
fait semblant d'être d'accord et on ne
l'est pas ou alors carrément on dit
qu'on ne l'est pas mais on ne peut pas
discuter on ne peut pas dialoguer le
doute ne saurait s'instaurer dans
l'apprentissage est un professeur
philosophie est avant tout là pour
développer l'esprit critique
merci marie laure segal d'avoir été avec
nous sur ce plateau fin et après cette
semaine bien chargée quoi de mieux que
de se détendre le week end comme chaque
vendredi c'est les agat son go nous
propose ses idées sorties et loisirs
et
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine nous allons parler bien
sûr de la saint valentin c'est le rendez
vous des amoureux
à ne pas manquer mais avant cela que
nous allons faire un peu de méditation
des ateliers bien-être en visio
conférences sont proposées par les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines
les derniers le dernier a eu lieu samedi
6 février et d'autres sont à prévoir
dans les prochains mois les images
d'astrid bergère vous allez essayer de
déverrouiller les épaules n'essayez pas
de les relever les épaules vos bras ils
sont où il son ballon le long du gore se
recentrer sur l'essentiel et apprendre à
mieux se concentrer les rendez-vous des
bulles de bien-être sont organisées par
le réseau des médiathèques de saint
quentin en yvelines
l'atelier ce jour s'y présenter la
méthode pour sa part le fait de prendre
sa vie en main guidée effectivement si
de leur faire découvrir alors quelques
joutes i parce que j'ai une boîte à
outils qui est très dense 2 2
deux issues de cette méthode de
relaxation qui sont donc clairement des
dix outils de gestion du stress et des
émotions
ce sont les praticiens de l'association
équilibre énergie qui anime ces ateliers
de deux heures en visioconférence autre
méthode pour vivre dans l'instant
présent
la réceptivité consciente des sensations
ont conscience on va utiliser une soeur
s'en sort il pourrait utiliser nos cinq
sens dans le contexte sanitaire actuelle
c'est bulle de bien-être permettent de
se sentir mieux dans son corps et dans
sa tête le coeur du sujet et la finalité
c'est surtout de faire du bien à toutes
ces personnes qui vont de plus en plus
mal parce que la situation s'éternise en
fait un et qui a pas de perspective
prochain rendez vous le samedi 10 avril
de 15 heures à 17 heures le programme
comment l'hypnose peut nous aider à
revenir à l'essentiel le bien-être passe
aussi par une bonne dose d'amour et cela
tombe bien la saint valentin c'est ce
week end et qui mieux pour parler
d'amour que notre journaliste michael et
demi d'euros vont faire un bon sens et
liage enfilé mon costume de cupidon
wingles pour vous merci fallait pas vous
avez déniché des bons plans assez sa
poursuite et idéalement la saint
valentin
exactement ce lien va tout de suite
prendre la direction de
voisins-le-bretonneux le restaurant la
ferme de voisins l'un des restaurants
les plus connus de la ville propose à
tous les amoureux une carte spéciale
pour l'occasion on écoute le menu du
chef qui nous donne déjà l'eau à la
bouche
alors le problème pour la saint valentin
c'est un beau menu avec un amuse-bouche
une entrée un plat et un dessert
on est partis sur des produits assez
sympa à partager un foie gras bien sûr
du nougat de son fumée tir frais en
entrée une volaille fermière avec des
mauries en plat et puis une rose un
petit peu particulière pour la saint
valentin pour concocter ce menu
romantique à 100 euros pour 2 toute
l'équipe est venue travailler cette
semaine alors que le restaurant est
fermé à cause du contexte sanitaire la
demande sera très forte plus de 200
repas ont déjà été précommandés oui oui
on veut déclarer sa flamme dans les
yvelines
ils seront disponibles en livraison ou
en cliquant de collecte en tant que
laboratoire c'est super important parce
que nous notre métier premier c'est la
convivialité c'est le partage c'est
donner du plaisir aux gens et si on en
donne pas au moment de la saint valentin
je vois pas quel hautement veut partager
un peu d'amour et de bonheur
attention ce restaurant prend les
commandes jusqu'à ce dimanche midi
pas plus tard et la ferme de gally
ascensions des cols fêtera aussi
l'événement la ferme de gally oui à
saint cyr l'école a décidé de mettre les
petits plats dans les grands
si vous voulez offrir un petit souvenir
dimanche des cadeaux spécial saint
valentin seront vendus en boutique
la structure proposera également
différents paniers gourmands à emporter
entre 25 et 50 euros
on écoute bruno gansel le responsable
communication qui a toujours des
produits autour de autour de cette
thématique de l'amour et de la saint
valentin avec de la confiture d'amour la
confiture de bisous des crocs amour du
chocolat noir à la fraise selon les cas
on peut y mettre une bouteille de
champagne de champagne rosé de cidre il
y a de quoi se faire plaisir pour passer
un bon moment
enfin ces liens que serait une saint
valentin à cent fleurs je sais que c'est
très important pour vous la ferme de
gally propose une grande variété de
bouquets on écoute bruno cancer il ya
une grande diversité de bouquets qui
seront proposés vous aurez des bouquets
qui seront déjà tout préparé avec la
traditionnelle rose rouge qui est la
fleur emblématique mais il y aura plein
d'autres pleins d'autres fleurs à
disposition de l'amaryllis et autres
donc avec des bouquets qui sont soit
préparée et puis également des
fleuristes 1 julie qu'est la fleuriste
du magasin qui sera à disposition des
des clients pour répondre à l'euro à
leur demande et faire des bouquets sur
mesure enfin si vous n'êtes pas trop au
repas cadeaux ou encore fleurs mais que
vous êtes plutôt déclaration d'amour
plusieurs villes vous propose de laisser
des petits mots doux à votre moitié sur
les panneaux municipaux ce sera le cas
villepreux bois d'arcy lavail encore
vélizy villacoublay
pour plus d'information il vous suffit
de vous rendre sur le site internet des
communes
peut-être que vous célia vous aurez
cette surprise ce dimanche 14 février
oui peut-être on verra bien
vous me calculer votre saint valentin
idéal un bon repas et vous la même chose
avec des chocolats toujours et chocolat
très important exactement merci beaucoup
vick avait nui d'euros d'avoirs était
avec nous la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet propose des animations pour
les vacances scolaires des petits
franciliens cette année avec la crise
sanitaire six ateliers se feront en
visio nous recevons aujourd'hui avec
nous par téléphone serait drieu bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le responsable des
animations
alors qu'est ce que vous proposez pour
ces vacances de février mais du coup
t'as pas vraiment une première pour le
fait années et qui ment malheureusement
nous ne pouvons pas accueillir les les
enfants sur leflux de la bergerie donc
on a en fait il ya trois semaines qu'il
fallait passer le pas et donc du coup on
a imaginé notre enquête à la ferme en
version en version virtuelle avec un
certain nombre d'énigmes sur le même
principe que ce qui aurait dû être
proposé sur le terrain c'est-à-dire de
découvrir quatre lieux emblématiques de
la ferme avec une problématique dans
chaque dans chaque espace
or comment ça va se dérouler les énigmes
combien y en a et est ce que tout se
passe sur facebook oui tout se battre
tout se passe sur facebook tous les
jours à 14h on donne rendez vous aux
enfants du premier jour au dernier jour
des vacances pour qu'on va commencer
samedi là il ya eu déjà une petite
annonce qui est fait depuis plusieurs
semaines donnant rendez vous aux enfants
dès samedi 14 heures et de 14 heures
voilà le commissaire scientifique qui
est le piquet de loïc de 10 me présente
aux enfants la problématique donc il ya
une organisation sur les quatre lieux
dont 4,4 à faycelles donc ça fait à peu
près c'est donc les 16 jours des
vacances et il y aura donc une dernière
vidéo qui fera le lendemain ou des
vacances pour expliquer aux enfants et
aux participants comment donner la bonne
réponse
d'accord et donc s'il ya combien
d'énigmes donc en tout il ya fait venir
mme différentes 1 c'est à dire que je
prends l'exemple des moutons l'énigme
numéro un
on explique le problème donc l'énigme
numéro est de retrouver dans quel lieu
se trouve le commissaire scientifique
parce que finalement les animaux ont un
peu le blues
les animaux ont quitté le site de la
bergerie il faut déjà aller retrouver
donc la première est la première des
énigmes c'est de retrouver dans quelle
maison dans quel abri se trouve le
commissaire de nuit avec un certain
nombre d' indices qui ont été cachés
dans la petite vidéo dont il ya une
petite vidéo qui va donc passer tous les
jours le jour numéro 2 donc l'énigme
numéro 2 on a enfin retrouvé la la la la
bonne maison qui donc en l'occurrence
ici la maison de moutons avec le mouton
qui reviennent et ensuite on va donc
expliquer qu'un objet a disparu donc ces
deux là il ya vraiment la notion du bien
être animal qui a abordé pour pour
chaque pour chaque élevage donc la ligue
et ça fera de retrouver un objet
emblématique de du mouton qui en
l'occurrence ici la tondeuse et on va
donc ensuite la troisième énigme c'est
la rencontre avec la bergère qui
explique les différentes étapes pour
tondre tondre un bouton et ans et enfin
la dernière énigme concerne les étapes
du travail de la laine et donc voilà à
chaque fois il ya des petites questions
il ya une thématique où est charlie où
il faut retrouver l'objet caché pour
faut bien écouter la bergère qui parle
avec la question qui est posée à la fin
et ainsi de suite donc là c'est la
première relire la première famille
c'est le mouton il ya la même chose chez
les vaches dans la basse-cour et chez
les chevaux d'accord et qu'est ce que
l'on peut trouver
qu'est ce que l'on peut gagner pardon
ainsi si on trouve toutes ces énigmes
tout les bat tous les enfants
participants repartiront repartiront à
partir du moment où nous aurons donné le
le que tous les jours il ya un symbole
qui retrouvait est le symbole fera
référence et d'autres l'alphabet
scientifique et ce symbole permettra à
l'ensemble des trains bol donc les 16
permettra aux enfants de retrouver un
mot important donc là je vais pas vous
le dire
et si la réponse est là est bonne les
enfants nous informe par par facebook de
de cette réponse et ils recevront une
entrée pour pour revenir à la bergerie
gratuitement dès qu'on pourra les
accueillir de nouveau bien sûr est ce
que d'autres animations sont à prévoir
sur sur les vacances la wii sur ses
vacances là et puis peut-être les
prochaines vacances est ce que ce sera
vision aussi là autant là on savait
qu'il fallait passer ce cap que pour les
prochains les prochains événements que
ce soit fin mars pour le week-end de la
tonte ou les vacances d'avril ont là du
coup on travaille actuellement sur les
deux cas de figure là la version en vrai
sur le terrain pour un chasse aux oeufs
c'est vrai que c'est bien plus simple
d'aller ramasser des oeufs en vrai est
par contre pour la seule la version
virtuelle on va essayer d'imaginer
l'imaginé une animation aussi différente
tous les jours pendant les 15 jours des
vacances mais d'avril merci beaucoup
frédéric drieu d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]
finir cette page loisirs je vous propose
une idée de sortie pour ce week end avec
une ballade romantique à faire pour la
saint valentin le long du canal de
l'yvette vous pourrez découvrir la
promenade des petits ponts à chevreuse
il y en a 22 tous différents on aperçoit
aussi sur le chemin de belles maisons en
pierre du village et aussi d'anciens
l'avoir et je sais twitter week end
continue avec eléonore pour parler de
l'actualité
[Musique]
pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end votre
rendez-vous en partenariat avec les
surligneurs ce collectif qui décrypte
les déclarations des personnalités
publiques et politiques
aujourd'hui retour sur la réouverture
sans autorisation des musées à perpignan
par le maire rassemblement national
louis aliot en écoute vincent couronne
docteur en droit à l'université
versailles saint quentin et fondateur
des cieux ligneurs le monde de la
culture s'émeut que depuis le 30 octobre
les musées soit fermée au public tous
les musées du château de versailles au
musée du tire bouchon dans le lubéron
l'amateur d'art et de culture trouve
porte close et c'est là que le maire
rassemblement national de perpignan
louis aliot tente de se faire une place
dans le débat en montrant qui soutient
le monde de la culture pour ce faire eh
bien il a pris cette semaine un arrêté
de réouverture des musées municipaux de
la ville
sauf que c'est illégal pourquoi et bien
pour comprendre il faut se plonger dans
la répartition des pouvoirs entre le
maire et le gouvernement
par principe le maire dispose de ce
qu'on appelle un pouvoir de police
générale
en d'autres termes c'est à lui en
premier lieu qui revient de protéger
l'ordre public ou encore la santé
publique
le premier magistrat de la ville est
donc celui qui est en première ligne
pour la protection de ses administrés ce
qui explique l'existence des polices
municipales ou encore qu'il revienne au
maire de décider de la fermeture de la
piscine pour cause de pollution de l'eau
on pourrait donc se dire qu'en vertu de
ce pouvoir de police générale
louis aliot pouvait en estimant que le
respect des gestes barrières suffirait à
protéger la santé des perpignanais
décidé de rouvrir ses musées sauf que
tout pouvoir à une limite et que la
limite de ce pouvoir de police générale
ici elle est fixée par le pouvoir de
police spéciale du gouvernement en
matière sanitaire le code de la santé
publique dans lé en effet à l'état le
pouvoir de prendre des décisions qui
s'imposent à tous pour protéger la santé
des français
et si l'état agit et bien le maire est
obligé de suivre c'est ce qu'on appelle
la hiérarchie des normes
c'est exactement le même principe qui
s'applique et lorsque les mères ont un
peu partout en france décidé de rouvrir
les commerces
et le sort de la décision de louis aliot
sur les musées connaîtra le même sort
l'annulation pure et simple par le juge
et la fermeture immédiate des musées de
la ville
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h en direct dans le 7-8
journal présenté par grégory canale et
d'ici là je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée et un très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o o
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]